para tratar de mitigar El impacto de
esta huelga 750 miembros de las fuerzas
militares conducirán las ambulancias y
prestarán ayuda logística pero no podrán
atender pacientes alrededor de 25.000
trabajadores que conducen las
ambulancias los paramédicos y quienes
atienden las líneas de emergencia en
Inglaterra y en gales han entrado en
este cese de actividades exigiendo
mejores salarios que estén acordes con
la disparada inflación en el país y el
gobierno les ha ofrecido un 4% algo que
los sindicatos han rechazado por ello se
ha pedido prudencia por parte de la
población para evitar emergencias y
quienes las tengan se les ha pedido que
lleguen a los hospitales en sus carros
propios o lo hagan en taxis en esta
situación varios hospitales en el país
han declarado la emergencia ante la
posibilidad o el temor de que no van a
poder atender a todas las pacientes
especialmente a quienes requieran una
ambulancia en este día en esta sensación
de cada día una huelga diferente de un
sector público distinto la población
tiene cada vez más la idea de que se
vive en una huelga general lo que está
poniendo mucha más presión en el
gobierno del Primer Ministro Richie